-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some jokes.
Well, guys, tomorrow,
President Biden is giving
a major speech on the next phase
of his pandemic response.
Americans said they
can't wait to hear the speech
and then crowd into a bar
for tomorrow's NFL kickoff.
Yeah, Biden wants to stop COVID
before more variants emerge.
He'll be like,
"Either you take this seriously
or you're going to have to learn
the whole Greek alphabet."
That's right --
Biden will lay out
a six-prong strategy
to fight COVID.
And, apparently,
one prong is building
a border wall between
the U.S. and Florida.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's all it is.
Just a wall.
♪♪
That's all it is.
-Oh!
-That's right --
it's a six-prong strategy.
Actually,
it's a six-word strategy --
"Quit it with the horse pills."
It's interesting.
Pretty soon,
Americans are going to be
looking at
eight flowcharts like,
"Alright,
we're on prong number 4,
Code Blue, Stage 7, Level 12.
So we can go to
Applebee's tonight.
Okay, we're allowed to do this."
Meanwhile, after taking a year
off because of the pandemic,
Macy's announced that
the public will once again
be able to attend the
Thanksgiving Day Parade
in New York City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's right.
That's right --
people will quickly realize
that standing for three hours
in the freezing cold
with their kids isn't
the "back to normal"
they've been missing.
It should be pretty safe.
I mean, not even COVID wants to
be near 700 volunteer clowns.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey, I saw this weekend,
former president Trump
is going to do ringside
commentary for a boxing match
in Florida.
Even Rudy Giuliani took a break
from Cameo to say,
"This is kind of sad."
Yep, Trump is going to do
boxing commentary.
It was like
he wasn't even president
and his life just picked up
right where it
left off, you know?
The fight is at the Hard Rock
Hotel & Casino in Florida.
It'll be crazy when Trump
walks through the door
and the casino
instantly goes bankrupt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, get this.
I read that people
here in the U.S.
are now spending more time on
TikTok than they are on YouTube.
When they heard,
your parents were like,
"Oh, come on.
We just figured out
how to get on the YouTube."
That's right --
people are spending more time
on TikTok than YouTube.
It's a pretty big deal.
I mean, when YouTube heard
the news, they were like...
-[ Bleats loudly ]
-Because YouTube has been
on top for a long time,
but TikTok just kind of waltzed
into the room like...
-How do democracies respond
to those candidate?
-And what will it mean for...
-YouTube didn't really see
this coming.
It totally blindsided
them like...
-There goes a couple of plows,
demonstrating --
-Seriously, it hit YouTube out
of nowhere, kind of like...
[ Both screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
But it makes sense that
TikTok is doing well.
I mean, all the dances
are so impressive.
Meanwhile, YouTube is like...
[ Ray Parker Jr.'s
"Ghostbusters" playing ]
-Long story short, for YouTube,
it's been a really far fall
from the top, kind of like...
[ Laughs ]
"Hey, Ron."
"How you doin', Billy?"
-"Hey, Billy."
[ Laughter ]
-Like that's remotely normal.
"Hey, Ron."
"How you doing there, Billy?"
-"How's it going?
You have that
wrench I was looking for?"
[ Laughter ]
-Some business news.
I saw that,
next year, Whole Foods
will open two stores
without cashiers.
That story again.
Starting next year,
groceries will be free
at two Whole Foods locations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whole Foods made the call after
they couldn't find a cashier
who could keep a straight face
while ringing up a $9 apple.
"Yeah, sure it's organic, yeah."
This is interesting.
According to a new study,
people spend 100 days
of their lives deciding what
TV shows and movies to watch.
Over three months only
to settle on,
"I'll watch whatever you want
and then quietly stew for
the next two hours."
And, finally, a 4-year-old girl
named Scarlett
just climbed her
48th mountain peak.
That's great, but she doesn't
have Instagram,
so did it really happen?
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen! Come on!
-♪ Design a finer rhyme
that's right on time ♪
♪ I'm a step beyond,
I'm not behind the line ♪
♪ Separate thought from divine ♪
♪ Better take it as a caution or
as a warning sign ♪
♪ The man at hand
that rule the school ♪
♪ And reach and teach the blind
and find from "A" to "Z" ♪
♪ And be the most to boast,
I'm loud and proud ♪
♪♪
-Hello, everybody!
Thank you so much for being --
Before we get started,
just a reminder, the NFL season
kicks off tomorrow night,
right here on NBC.
It is the
Bucs versus the Cowboys.
And we have a big, big show
right after the game.
John Cena will be here
in studio.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be doing something
fun with him.
Plus, global music superstar
J Balvin will be stopping by.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be talking to him,
and he's got
an amazing performance
you don't want to miss.
It's all happening
tomorrow night.
Set your DVRs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tune in, NBC tomorrow night.
But, first, what a show we have
for you tonight.
This Sunday, he and Jon Stewart
are putting on a show called
"NYC Still Rising After
20 Years: A Comedy Celebration"
at Madison Square Garden.
Pete Davidson is here tonight!
-Yeah, Peter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-Dude, he's the --
That's our dude.
-That's our man.
-Plus, she stars in the new film
"Vacation Friends" on Hulu.
Meredith Hagner is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we've got a great in-studio
performance tonight
from Baby Keem!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's awesome, by the way.
I saw rehearsals,
and, ooh, man, it's great.
Guys, do you ever see a photo
in the news and think,
"That headline could be
much better"?
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "News & Improved."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ "News & Improved" ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
That headline could definitely
be improved,
because if you
only looked at the photo,
the headline could've been...
-Chomp!
-You see how this works?
Alright, let's check out
this next photo.
The original headline was...
But if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline could've been...
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could've been...
"Up top."
No?
Next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Posh English accent ]
Three more beans, please.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Posh English accent ] Yes.
-Thank you.
Just three more beans, please.
[ Laughter ]
I'll have his beans, as well.
[ Normal voice ]
This next headline was...
The headline could've been...
[ Laughing ]
"How you doing?
Picked it up earlier."
Next headline was...
Headline could've been...
Thousandaire.
-Thousandaire.
-And, finally,
this headline was...
Headline could've been...
That's all the time we have
for "News & Improved."